and that leads me to the story of a
missing woman whose fiance returned from
a cross-country trip without her newly
released video shows what looks like the
aftermath of an argument between gabby
petito and brian laundry the body cam
comes from utah police officers who
question the couple potito's parents are
demanding answers from laundry's family
after all he returned home to florida
alone our national correspondent jericho
duncan has more on the search for potato
and the new evidence of a troubled
cross-country road trip
in police body camera footage from
august 12 gabby petito seemed distraught
she and her fiance brian laundry had
just been pulled over by police in moab
utah after a possible domestic incident
and you would have let me in the car
before why wouldn't you let you in the
car because you because
you told me i needed to calm down
but i'm perfectly calm down all the time
while potito said in the back of a
police cruiser laundry spoke with
officers nearby
so you pushed her and she hit you
i wasn't it wasn't like a push and she
jumped on me she's hearty
she was already
i don't know
neither were charged with a crime but
they were separated for the night
i think our plan for today is to just
hang out the couple had been on a
cross-country road trip since early july
however petito's family has not heard
from her since late august two people
went on a trip one person returned and
that person that returned isn't
providing us any information tell me
what's going on laundry is now a person
of interest in his fiancee's
disappearance stephen bertolino
represents the laundry on behalf of the
laundry family i will hope that miss
petito is located and that she's
reunited with her family yesterday
petito's family attorney rick stafford
read a scathing letter from gabby's
parents addressed to the laundries
gabby lived with you for over a year
she's going to be your daughter-in-law
how can you keep her location hidden
please tell us where gabby is located
tell us if we are even looking in the
right place as a search ramps up in
wyoming petito's father is desperate to
find her whatever you can do to make
sure my daughter comes home
i'm asking for that help
investigators say they're not ruling out
a connection between gabby's
disappearance and the murder of a couple
found dead at a utah campsite last month
laundry and his parents are not speaking
on the advice from his lawyer police say
they're frustrated by laundry silence
but he's exercising his constitutional
right and this morning i actually had
reached out to ricky clinton our cbs
news analyst and sort of got her take on
it and she said you know he doesn't have
to speak he can remain as quiet as he
wants to obviously it's frustrating for
the parents they don't understand it
they said you loved my daughter you guys
were engaged why wouldn't you want to
help us or say something to us to to
reassure us that she's still with us
she's somewhere maybe she's you know
waiting for someone to help her they
they're holding on to hope i don't
understand the law here tarika i just
don't understand how you can go away on
a trip with someone you're seeing on
tape where there was an argument that
the police were called right and you can
just come back and not say anything at
all about it i just don't know how you
can how you are allowed to do this yes
right
constitutional right to not speak i mean
and the police the police have said they
know exactly where he is and if they
need to get him and pick him up they
will right
yeah but we don't know where she is i'm
so that's the most important thing so
worried about her and the family jerica
we thank you to be continued for sure
only on cbs morning's